in other news online gambling operators
32 red and platinum gaming I'm sure
you've heard of them have been fined
more than seven million pounds between
them the gambling commission says it's
for their failures and social
responsibility and anti-money laundering
efforts what's all this about Matthew
has more for us this morning who are
these companies and what they've been up
to well they're two of the most
prominent gambling companies in the
country in fact and the scale of the
fine is large let's make no bones about
it but the gambling commission has shown
it's prepared to make these sorts of
fines in the past as to what they've
done
it's essentially failures to identify
and protect problem gamblers if we take
32 Red limited which runs 32red.com they
fail to identify problem gambiners
gamblers based on the length of their
gambling sessions they allowed one
problem Gambler to deposit 43 000 pounds
and lose 36 000 pounds in the space of a
week wow yeah and these two companies
they're actually connected Platinum
gaming which runs unibet.com they're
both part of something called the
Kindred group and one of the other
failings was based offshore both
actually based in Gibraltar as many
gambling companies are they one of the
other problems that garment commission
identified was that these problem
gamblers on 32red.com were able to
register even though they've been
blocked they would be able to register
on Platinum gaming and continue gambling
even though they're the same even though
they're part of the same group now we
have a short statement from the Kindred
Group after this fines were issued they
told us that Kindred acknowledges and
appreciates the commission's clear
recognition that the group's UK
operation is in an improved position
since the assessment took place and that
it remains suitable to hold an operating
license our commitment to reducing
gambling harm across our platforms is a
key part of our journey towards zero
ambition and we're redoubling our
efforts to ensure we continue that
progress okay I'd be interesting to see
what their profits are um good to talk
to you Matthew thanks very much indeed
well joining us now a Charles and Ms
Ritchie who set up the organization
gambling with lives after they lost
their son to gambling addiction in 2017
we've chatted a couple of times before
haven't we and thanks for joining us on
a short notice really appreciate it I
wonder what your thoughts are
um a on the fine seven million pounds
and be on on what the um
statement was from the organization that
represents these two companies
well I think first of all Kay I'd quite
like to address the idea that people are
called Problem gamblers if that's okay
and then Charles could maybe talk about
that because he's better at me at that
um the problem is that we've got problem
products and problem selling so the
problem products are very addictive
they're more addictive than class A
drugs and they're pushed down the throat
of our young people and that's exactly
what happened to our our son you know
these these products more addictive than
heroin were right by school and now
they're online they're in everybody's
pocket on their smartphone so we really
got to move away from talking about
problem gamblers anybody can be a
problem Gambler because anybody could be
addicted to heroin if they were given an
armful of it
yeah Charles um that's a very
interesting point and we we heard um
about a young man I believe he lost uh
he gambled
um 48 40 odd thousand pounds lost 36 000
pounds in the space of just uh a week
these fines have been issued to these
two companies that have won
umbrella organization find of just over
seven million pounds allowed to keep
their license and the company saying
we're getting better
well I mean I think I think the thing is
and as your your piece said these are
high street names these aren't
Backstreet um minor uh players in the
field these are you know High Street
companies everybody knows them and a
fine of 7.1 million really is just a
fraction of the massive profits they
make and I think it's absolutely worth
remembering that Platinum will find 1.6
million in 2018. 32 Red were fined 2
million pounds in 2019. Kindred have
been fined in Sweden the Netherlands
Poland since those fines and still these
practices go on you know we we as
gambling Rich lives are dealing with
cases which are current these aren't
historical it's something that the
industry keeps on saying we're getting
better we're getting better they used to
use the appalling phrase we didn't we
weren't Best in Class
they are still not Best in Class you
know that we we are dealing with deaths
which happened literally in the the last
few weeks and there are High Street
operators involved in those cases this
is happening today and I'm afraid that
fines of this level really are not going
to uh really Dent the practices that
have got to be licenses renewed uh
removed
and individuals held responsible within
the companies understood now there's you
know we can talk about the fines we can
talk about fines that haven't been paid
before we can talk about people that
have lost money but
um when we hear your story it really
brings it home I know it's difficult for
you to tell us what happened to Jack but
I think it's probably important for
people to realize what can happen just
tell us what you want to tell us
uh well uh Jack was a very very happy
baby very normal happy child but as as I
said before the the point was they were
these products that were more addictive
than heroin were in the High Street
right by school and a large group of the
sick form used to go out and uh Gamble
during their dinner hour with their
dinner money Jack was the one who was
addicted he was free of it for many many
months at a time uh for years in fact
um and then he will have got a promotion
while he was he was abroad he was
teaching English as a foreign language
he was a very intelligent highly
successful young man and he will have
got a promotion and then he just felt
totally despairing and he left a very
clear suicide note
and then at his inquest so at his
inquest which was heard under article
two of the human rights act so it was
the first inquest like this
um the coroner was absolutely appalled
he would he he he said it was completely
woefully inadequate because the
information for us and for him was
industry funded pro-industry information
and uh um and the treatment has been
industry funded so you know it is really
about time that the government
got the white paper out and it won't be
everything that we need but it will be a
start
okay uh I know it's always difficult to
talk about it but thank you for sharing
those amazing pictures of your young lad
with us as well who died at the age of
just uh 24. um come on the show whenever
you want to guys yeah thanks for always
coming on really appreciate it you're
welcome anytime thank you for having us
thank you
if you have been affected by this story
and want to talk to somebody you can
call the Samaritans free 116123 or you
can email Joe at
samaritans.org 116123 or email if you
prefer Joe samaritans.org it's all
completely confidential